you just mentioned this is the last one
people are you taking a step back from
phil i need to be in the place that
makes me happiest and i just want to be
24 7 with my babies and my family that's
it i enjoyed your book about the lost
city and i believe you're the one who
can help me find its treasure i have to
respectfully decline i'm afraid i must
insist
congratulations on this film loved every
second of it it was absolutely
hysterical daniel you said that your
parents were there last night at the
premiere sandra you said that your kids
were able to be on set so what does
everyone think of the film
mom and dad fully approve really like it
yeah no they would they were my mom and
dad they're a good audience they're not
like gonna sit there and be judgmental
they're very much like parents who i
don't know how bad i would have to make
something for them to not love it but
they no they were lovely and they had a
great time they loved seeing you as the
villain yeah i think they also just like
seeing me with the haircut and in some
nice suits i think for a change but yeah
i think they enjoyed that and you
mentioned at the premiere that your kids
were on set with you they were have they
seen the final film no they get to see
it in l.a it'll be their first um
i've never had them come to a premiere
they'll back door it
lila really wants to be on the carpet
and i was like it's not happening i
think you do
yeah you don't but they get to see it
and they all get to invite a friend this
will be the first time out of this sort
of dark cloud of the pandemic that they
get to
feel some kind of feeling of normalcy
that's cool yeah and celebrating with
mom that's so fun
do you have harry potter fans in the
household are you getting some cool mom
points here starting with that i don't
want to say yes
but i've only really asked one person
for an autograph
that's very flattering and it was for my
sister
okay and i purchased a sort of a gold
gilded frame and and uh
and uh it's sitting on her shrine i'm
proud of playing he did me a solid he
did myself wow have you always been a
fan of this lovely lady here what's one
of your favorite sandra movies i mean
like that there literally are so many
the one that like i i feel like i talked
about a bit is while he was sleeping
because that was one that we watch every
christmas in our house but like speed is
also a phenomenal movie still like it is
so good um
and i miss congeniality i remember
seeing it yeah there's like you know
just had a very good career
no it's not
this is the last one people must be like
your first
it wasn't the first first one but it was
the first one that sort of hit
unexpectedly big you know it was it was
a surprise there we were a movie about a
bomb on a bus
circling at the airport it's possible
i mean look at what it became and it had
this guy in it that like
i mean what happened to him i don't know
yeah he's out there
you just mentioned this is the last one
people are you joking with that or you
are taking a step back from phil i you
know right now and don't know how long
that'll be
i need to be in the place that makes me
happiest and and i take my job very
seriously when i'm at work and it's 24
7.
and i just want to be 24 7 with my
babies and my family that's it and we
don't know how long or how short but
it's that's where i'm going to be for a
while what mom tivoties are you looking
forward to the most
you know servicing their every need
their social calendar um
you know there's extra steps you have to
take because we're still in a pandemic
you know it's like i i've all the
parents know me as the crazy lady with
the pandemic so they know their children
will return without covid when they've
come to our house so i i'm on them all
the time i love that you mentioned the
social calendar because they got a red
carpet to hit soon
yeah no they're going in the back door i
don't care how much she screams and
she's not getting on the carpet yeah
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover mind i'll start living
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you now we have to talk about
this all star cast obviously aside from
you two we have channing tatum and brad
pitt is it true obviously you mentioned
at the premiere that
brad kind of signed on because you're
mutual hair stylist
coordinated you appearing in his movie
he's appearing exactly what happened is
there any truth to the rumor that you
basically threatened george clooney to
call brad pitt almost every day to join
okay why does everyone think i need
george to do my dirty work
no it literally was threatening brad
pitt herself i do my own threats i don't
think george to help me threaten people
um
no it was just janine janine and
brokering the deals for both of us and
uh it was it was a woman
that did it don't name george when did
that rumor start
between last
like has george and brad like connected
at the hip right you know because i
assume that they like live in each
other's homes they like share wives like
i don't know it's like i feel like they
can't you know no so no george i didn't
i didn't need george for that one i need
him for other things but not that and as
you mentioned at the premiere you paid
everyone well to be a part of the
project yes i mean you were rescued by
brad pitt and channing tatum in this
film i mean this is not too shabby of a
gig or did i rescue channing well yes
that is true
my character does doesn't actually get
rescued at the end
she she is a part of the rescue which
that's what i liked about it she got to
be like the guy and you make the
decision to like this is how we get out
yeah yep i do love that now the scene
with the leeches
what was that like on set and how long
did that take to pull everything off and
that was on day two of filming right
yeah to pull everything off well there's
a lot of resetting literally pull it off
i pulled them off and then they had to
be reset um
the fun part of that day was once we got
the scene the the knee brothers who are
directors are some of the funniest
people you will ever meet so then they
decided to start throwing out other
monologues and lines while i was on my
knees you might as well just keep going
and i went
uh they threw out some of the funniest
lines that couldn't be used because i
could not keep a straight face i would
get maybe three quarters of the way
through
but it it was like channing is so
comfortable
with himself he knew it was for comedy
he wasn't trying to be serious he worked
really hard to make sure when his
rear end turned into
frame that it was perfect i mean i
looked i looked for imperfections and i
did not see it did not see anything no
it's it's also it's very smooth really
we didn't have to do any like visual
effects fixes it was it's just like a
little baby's bottom just like all up in
there and smooth
they told me on the carpet yesterday
that you've been championing i'm gonna
pay for this you know that's okay
shut down yeah
she's gonna be very happy oh good she
got it across that there's there's no
blemishes oh yeah after hearing all of
this you don't want to go for channing
tatum's role
ah no i mean you're good i i've got my
kit off enough in my own life i don't
need to try and start doing that as well
on this movie no i gotta go
just said that was a little bit of
english
bloomy shrimp on the barbie wait you
said bloody shrimp on the barbie that's
australian i know but you kind of went
there you kind of took a left
i didn't know i didn't know where you
went there just all jumbled together
yeah i just i just i just yeah i get
increasingly english sometimes sorry you
sure did
not daniel next up for you you are
taking on the weird al biopic yeah this
transformation is unbelievable how long
did that take you uh no like everyone
looks at it and it's like oh this is
real translation i drew them start so
the massages was mine um because i
didn't want to wear a fake one every day
um and you know the the wigs are wigging
it's a great week and they they get it
on but it's it's pretty quick um in
terms of like um evan who plays madonna
like that was a much uh you know
obviously she's a much more involved
process but um we had an amazing hair
makeup team like truly truly i don't
know how they did what they did in 18
days so it was um you know all down to
them what can fans expect um the
absolutely 100 true story of al's life
i'm gonna keep that going for as long as
i can i was like wow that's insane that
came out pretty solidly
um yeah no it's going to be a lot of fun
hopefully